let's go to adam in syracuse new york
adam what's going on oh no
not much dr dean just come back from
work um
calm because i was wondering how to get
my wife on board with everything that
dave says
uh you know i've been doing the program
since uh
late january and i got about
forty thousand dollars in debt uh not
including her vehicle with her vehicle
it'd be about 55
and i just want to change my family tree
and be able to purchase our first home
by next year
oh man well i appreciate your heart dude
and congratulations on turning this
first corner here
rachel you've heard this question for
years and years talking with couples
yeah so adam what's her biggest
hesitation what
what causes her not to want to get on
board
um well she's she works full-time as a
nurse at the va
and she's also going to school
for her rn and i think she's really
focused on that
which i'm super proud of her for but i i
really don't know her hesitation
he when i first mentioned dave to her
she got out
online read some negative reviews and
i'm like those are out there for all of
us yeah
i'm like believe what you want to
believe i go this guy is making absolute
sense to me
and i'm with it it's just hard to do it
by yourself
yeah you're right it's almost impossible
to do it by yourself if two of you are
not on the same page
okay so what i so it doesn't sound like
she is
because i talked to some people in the
spouse is like oh i don't want a budget
because i just want to have fun and not
be accountable
or some people say i just want to
continue to do what i do because
i i deserve it you know i mean like
there's kind of some entitlement
issues that i hear a lot but i don't
hear that from her i just hear that
she's
of skeptical process so
i mean she she's the saver and i'm the
spender and yeah
um i'm i limit myself on everything oh
so
well i was gonna ask i mean i just so i
wonder if it just
sounds like a really big thing to to to
bite off for her because she has all
these other things she's doing and she's
thinking oh this thing is going to
take over but what you both have to
understand is that yes when we say work
as a married couple you definitely work
together
but one of you naturally is probably
gonna do more and be more excited than
the other like winston
he's the nerd in our relationship like
he's the one that honestly does the
excel
he we do every dollar for a monthly but
he has an excel thing to map out
the future he always wants to talk he
you know he'll want to talk about it i'm
the one that's like uh
i kind of want to watch the bachelor
like i don't like you know that doesn't
mean i'm not on board but i'm not as
excited as he is or he's the one that
pays all of our bills he
he does it all even though i know what's
being paid and we're on the same page so
so for her she just you just need her to
you guys come together and agree hey we
want to start this process but the heavy
lifting of the tactical day-to-day
can honestly come from you adam and that
that's okay from from our perspective
adam how did you bring it up to her um
you know we were laying in bed one night
talking yeah that's your problem right
stop are you serious okay so it's great
you're laying in bed you roll over and
you flutter your eyelashes at her
and she flutters our eyelashes back at
you and you say baby have i got a deal
for you is that how that went
yeah kind of come on man you got to be
more smooth than that how long have you
been married
11 11 years together yeah 11 years
oh adam man okay so a couple things that
you said that i want to make sure
are you a schemer have you always had
some things
do you always are you the guy who brings
good ideas she's a saver she's a nurse
she's
working in hospital like she's she's
predictable making it happen yeah are
you the guy with like hey
listen yeah
yeah i think i am so you when you first
called
you talked about her car payment your
debt
and so what i would tell you is you guys
have a pronoun problem
and what i mean is if you have a you
and a her in a marriage and then the you
is
coming to the uh oh i'm sorry you're not
here you're just together okay
you all been together for 11 years yeah
we have two children together and
we've been together for 11 years okay so
if you haven't committed right if y'all
are just riding this out together as
a in a committed relationship why aren't
y'all married can i ask yeah you can ask
um i i think she's afraid of commitment
she afraid she's with you for a decade
brothers it sounds like she's afraid of
you
[Laughter]
that could be that very well could be
adam you know the truth is is that is
that real is that real
uh honestly i don't know
but you're probably right on the money
so here's what i would suggest brother
i would suggest sitting down with her
and talking about what's the future
going to look like
when you have two kids when you're not
married when you've been together for a
decade
suddenly the days turn into weeks and
the weeks turn into months and suddenly
you've been together three years and
five years and we'll think about this
later and suddenly the future starts to
happen in front of you
and that's when one of you peels off to
go back to school to start trying to
create their own future because we're
clearly not on the same page i've got
mine you've got yours
i'm gonna go make some more money for me
so i can get a different car for me and
suddenly
you're gonna wake up and you're both
gonna be sitting on a couch and you're
gonna be two inches apart from each
other you can be two thousand miles away
from one another
and coming in with something like this
program which is we've gotta work
super close together not close together
we have to be one on this deal
because it's hard and it is back and
forth and
months on top of months and suddenly you
wake up and you're
a united couple and you're two or three
years down the road and you have this
entire new trajectory so when you talk
about want to change your family tree
right now you got two plants in the same
house so at first you got to do is you
got to
decide we're going to have one tree
we're going to do this one thing
together
and we're going to raise these kids in a
certain way we're going to build a
future together and a part of building a
future together rachel
is we're going to do money together
right so your heart is right adam
your spirit is right your ideas are
right but they're just out of order
right now
and the first thing you got to do is to
circle back to this extraordinary woman
you've
you've you've created a life with the
last decade plus
and say hey let's make this a unified
thing moving forward right
for sure and the richness that comes
from that so not just
the commitment to say we're gonna get
married not just the commitment that
we're gonna work together through money
not just the commitment that we're gonna
do parenting together
well like that whole life that you're
bringing together it's almost like all
these separate puzzle pieces and you
start to bring it together and it is a
beautiful thing
while i feel like people it's dog
marriage it's stable
yes there's something about it that the
richness of your life it increases
because there's a level of vulnerability
and um unity that you've never
experienced before
to say hey we're going to be in this
together and it's
it's something that i feel like is it
it enhances your life and it's something
about there's something about being
tethered in
being anchored in not even knowing that
yeah and i'm gonna fall off this
mountain sometimes
but i'm not gonna die right i may bang
up the side of it but i'm anchored into
something
yeah and somebody may shove me off she
may shut me off
but we are anchored in here right and
yeah it's circling back to we got to be
on the same page
working to gather
how hard is it so you guys how long have
you all been married 11
11 years okay there's a myth that
all of a sudden you wake up and you
figured it out and there's no more
discussions no more eye rolls no more
whatever when it comes to budgets
right that's not true right no
no i mean i think the logistical side of
the budget goes pretty quick
like the budget meeting quote unquote
like we'll talk when we do it and it
sounds like oh of course she does but we
really really do
yeah before the month begins we sit down
we're like hey let's look at march okay
well we're going
to the beach this week on spring break
we're going to do this and this and you
start kind of mapping out and we
and so all of that takes eight to ten
minutes like we do that fast
but it's the other parts of knowing
being known by each other
in a deep way because money is it's it
reveals
a lot of who you are and so working that
closely with your spouse
yeah can create some moments where like
oh i mean i'll be honest like i love
amazon right now i know people hate
amazon but i'm like i can't stop
and and like and it's under his like he
created the account years ago whenever
we got prime and so we obviously just
share the account but i know every time
i buy something
it's he gets a notification i'm always
like even though it's in the budget and
i know it
i'm the spender and he's the saver so
even those things and i'm like hey just
heads up
i'm getting um a new pan because our
non-stick
you know we really need in the house and
we need it
but it creates it just creates the
conversation that's right that's just
what i love
so and so for those of you out there who
are three years in five years in
it does get easier it gets more routine
but it always brings you back to a
conversation that's right
right that's right we had one at tractor
supply this week and me and my wife oh
we'll hear about that we won't
this is the ramsay show